foreign
he's very good at what he does I steal
them from him but yeah would you trust a
female cop to stop a sexual assault what
do you mean by Trust
if a woman's getting sexually assaulted
would you trust a female cop to start it
so you're calling the police and they
send a woman do you trust her I mean I'd
assume that a man could overpower her so
so no okay
I would trust her to try the best of her
ability to stop it because she is a
police officer and that is her job to
protect and serve and that's why she was
called to the situation
[Music]
guy may end up getting shot I don't see
how you know she just because she's in
the uniform she might be able to
overpower him
you know I don't see
um
that happening you know he probably
shoot the guy or something but actually
literally stopping it I don't know I
don't think so
I think yeah me answering as a female I
would feel safer just someone else being
there because I think like maybe with
two of us we would be able to stop him
as opposed to just me on my own so you
would trust yeah I mean I'd feel better
if it was a man but it is what it is
okay
the the female officer is empowered
has methods that a bystander wouldn't be
allowed to use she can use weapons she
can call her back up
um if she does use lethal Force she has
the protector whereas a bystander
wouldn't
so what I feel more protected of a woman
officer coming up to stop my sexual
assault
um no but
would she as a female officer feel more
enabled to end that sexual assault I
think so
so if I was a woman however I agree with
you 100 just having the other person
there makes that assaulter kind of freak
out would he stop could that woman stop
him I don't know but maybe she had her
weapons maybe but the bystander no so I
think the female cop
yes could stop it but um females in
general I don't think would be able to
I think I would like um because it comes
down to also skill
and if she has a weapon as well like I
hope she has a gun uh but if you ask me
I'm hanging from a cliff and there's a
man and a woman who would I picked to
lift me up it would obviously be a man
when it comes to power yeah I would
trust a man but because of skill and
training yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
really have a problem yeah the things in
the UK like police officers don't have
guns and stuff so like if it was
happening here wouldn't you just rather
I don't even know what happens here oh
yeah oh yeah UK and police officers
don't have guns also yeah definitely a
man yeah it just hit me I was thinking
about NYPD strong
is the is the question pertaining to
a woman being sexually assaulted or if
it was
at the the individual in general
if a woman's being sexually assaulted so
what about if it was a man is that not
relevant to what you're I'm I mean the
the perpetrator is a man in both
scenarios
I mean if he's able to overpower me if
the guy's able to overcome you I'd
assume be able to also overpower the
female of a sudden so okay yeah
why are men expected to be protectors if
it is said that women are just as
capable
um you know because it's their duty
if you're not my mum my sister my girl
significant other a friend I will not
protect you like I'm sorry like I don't
know what you've done I don't know who
you've you know that shows
but what I'm saying is if I just see
someone on the street arguing with their
boyfriend and he happens to say I'm
sorry I'm walking away yeah I'll call
the policeman I'm walking away okay so
this happened like a year ago
I was in dulston I'm going through like
the thing this this guy this tall guy
like walks up on this woman you can see
from her face she was like terrified
didn't know it from Eve but like
I just walked up to her and I said you
know not looking at the guy I said um
are you ready let's go you know are you
all right you know and the guy just
looked at me and I could see he was
gazing I mean he just walked away so and
then when he walked away I just said oh
you're right and I just and she's like
nod and I just turned away so
I understand what you're saying you like
don't want to get you you don't want to
get tangled up in it but at the same
time like the kind of dude I'm I'd still
be walking away like yo okay but what
what if what if that was her boyfriend
right and you ended up getting in a
fight with him go to prison and then she
goes back to him afterwards wouldn't you
feel like a [__] I'm sorry I'm not
I'm not putting my life on the line or
even like an extreme that happens oh no
that happens all the time it happens so
many times man and it's like why should
I put my life on a line for a situation
I don't even know the ins and outs of
yeah I mean I
I definitely understand that part
um I have a question what if she's
getting raped
grapes is a bit different okay because
no matter what's happening that's wrong
you know so yeah you know no matter
what's happening that's always wrong so
I would intervene but if it's just
someone again if I I'm calling the
police like okay let me ask you what if
it was like a massive dude
excuse me this girl I'd still try to do
something I could please do but I still
try to do something that's completely
different it's always I think it's
always wrong yeah you know obviously
it's wrong it comes down to like your
safety as well yeah of course but that's
I think it's a bit different in that
situation I gotta say when when you're
seeing it happen yeah
the Judgment call comes in a little
different to what like in reality about
what we might classes are actually for
this man to protect I think like the
first thing
yeah that's why I think girls get away
with a lot of stuff too is they know
that they know if they they act a
certain way in public men will come to
their rescue because you see them in
court crying and stuff because like our
default is like oh protect she's crying
she's hurt you know how many times girl
doing something to a guy and then her
boyfriend having to Bear the
repercussions of her doing that thing
together so you know a woman starting on
the man and then that man punching her
boyfriend up can I I think that's
starting to reverse the so now I I've
experienced it personally I used to open
the door for every woman young or old
and so many times have I had to say
thank you for them
and I'll say it loud oh you're welcome
you know and and what I'm walking away
thinking is like you know what that's
the last time I ever opened a door for a
woman seriously and and I've I I'm
ashamed to say that I sought because it
changed me in the negative I think
that's something I should do for
everyone I was taught that that's what
you do for a woman I believe that's
wrong I think that's something you do
for everyone but I see that the chivalry
that a lot of women like to see in guys
is kind of disappearing
I think we're in a state where one group
of us wants it the other group of us
wants to do it but doesn't see the point
and actually gets a lot of crap you know
what I've noticed so we're just kind of
like at